i know half of the people in the room
but for those that don't i'm reed
lifsett
i'm the associate director of the
industrial environmental management
program
and this is a lecture series on business
and the environment that we've been
running for over 20 years
it's
funded by a modest endowment
in memory of joel kurahara who was a
graduate of the forestry school and the
embankment school
in 1991 he worked with
conrail in the global environmental
management initiative
and when he died his co-workers and
family established a fund in his memory
dedicated to dialogue among stakeholders
so
we
are pleased to have the support
this every year we pick a theme for this
lecture series and this year the theme
is industrial ecology is a source of
competitive advantage
and
um we're in this series we've got our
visitors today um earlier this month we
had uh the ceo of sustain u a company
that makes apparel out of um only
recycled materials from the us
on april 15th we're having a webinar
with some folks from mercedes
who are quite interesting because they
have
routinized the use of life cycle
assessment in their product development
process
and we'll end the series on the 22nd
with the ceo of a company called
foresight that is doing work to
establish an eco-industrial park
so the question is why this theme well
industrial ecology is the foundation for
the industrial environmental management
program here
for the few of you who may not know this
term it refers to
the pursuit of sustainable production
and consumption
typically through
a focus on materials and energy flows at
different scales
and it includes uh
oh you could say that the the famous
question of
paper versus plastic falls under the the
rubric of industrial ecology so there's
life cycle assessment material flow
analysis eco-industrial parks uh
sustainable materials use
uh among the the topics that industrial
oncology encompasses
but the reason why we're having the
lecture series this year is we wanted to
um
see if there we could show a business
case for the clever ideas that come out
of industrial ecology see if there's um
traction in the real world
so today we have the pleasure of having
um the founder and ceo and the director
let's see if i get the title right
director of
uh environment and environmental
technology and material science here
from preserve
a company that has been doing um work in
precisely this area
i'm not going to steal their thunder by
talking about the company itself i think
they'll do a better job than i will but
let me just say something about our
speakers
eric hudson is our founder is the
founder and ceo and he started the
company in 1996
he's from massachusetts
um he comes from a family very rich in
entrepreneurialism
including the grandparents who are
founders of brookstone
he work he's worked in operations
management and trading at fidelity and
he has also established his own
consulting firm but i think his his big
baby here is is preserve
john lively
who i said is the director of
environmental technology and material
science has been working with the
company for a long time as well
he has a ba from some small school
on the charles river in boston
in environmental science and public
policy
and for the industrial ecologists in the
room you'll be interested to know that
he's actually had a course with um the
man himself robert frosh who wrote the
the famous article that is said to have
really started the field
so we expect a lot out of you
so the plan here is um
to
have a talk for about 45 plus minutes
and then some q a
so thank you for coming and
here we have uh the the dueling speakers
thank you very much reed
everybody hear me okay
thank you john
um let's start in with the first line
it's a pleasure to be here today um
we've had some some great
budding new relationships with yale
a couple of uh very good interns two
years ago and one who's in the crowd
today from from last summer
and i think we have one coming up this
summer so we we're value highly our
relationship with yale
i started preserve in 1996
to reuse earth's resources to make
products
from materials that have been used
before
and to make them fabulous products that
there'd be no sacrifice in in choosing
these products um amongst the the dark
greens light greens and any anything
you know in between or beyond dark
browns
so a lot of people choose our products
today not knowing anything about the
environmental side of them
we are number one selling in the natural
channel we have three products that uh
have done very well
in the whole foods market and beyond of
the world
and we've been recognized as a leader in
extended producer responsibility
particularly with our gimme five program
which we'll talk more about but also
mostly from day one we chose to take
back our products when they're finished
and then give them a new life
and we'll be talking a lot about that
today
and we have a pension for partnerships
one of our core values is to to work
with other companies uh to work with
other organizations and try to extend
out the mission that we have at preserve
uh beyond what we're capable of um
oftentimes
people consumers stakeholders will think
well much larger than we are because of
the expanse of our relationships
than you know how many products that we
sell
next time john
so reusing earth's resources what does
that mean it's taking the natural gas or
oil that's caught up in a yogurt cup uh
in a package in a product
and recovering it and then turn it back
into a product that we bring into the
marketplace
in addition
we created a system to take back that
product from day one so the preserved
toothbrush was the first product that
we created
and the goal was not only to make it out
of yogurt cups or other recycled
materials but also to capture it back
from the consumer when they were done
with it
we started with a a mailer that
got a lot of debate but
in essence it was the smallest mailer
that we could create without the post
office saying you can't do that take
back program through the system with a
really small mailer that used very
limited resources we had to have it a
certain size
so in a lot of ways we are you know
handing out these mailers in the early
days and you know your natural consumer
was saying does that make sense are you
creating you know sort of more waste
here than than you want to
is there a downside to this um so you
know we were on
a mission to try to get back as much of
the products as we could at a time in
these mailers so it's sort of the
beginning of this education process or
an information sharing process with our
consumer of trying to get them to bulk
mail as much back to us at a time so
that we weren't using you know more
resources than we wanted to to create
that new product after the toothbrush
um
the other side of this was you know that
the the stonyfield farm partnership came
in about 2000 so we started in 1996. and
about 2000 we were able to establish a
relationship with stonyfield farm
that really brought the identity of the
recyclable that was turning into the
toothbrush in the early days it was you
know we were making it out of recycled
materials and that was that was
interesting that was novel
most things made out of recycled
materials in those days were
ashtrays
or you know pen holders and no one
talked about that it was made out of
recycled materials it was maybe just a
a more a cheaper way to make a product
so to actually you know take something
from the recycling stream and make a new
product out of it
was it was a novel idea back then
certainly a product that one you know
would would put in their mouth we set
the bar very high on trying to make a
high quality product from recycled
materials
and then also in 2000 transitioned to
this message about the yogurt cup and
that really brought home the story to a
lot of our preservers as we like to call
them um they were able to really
identify that that that material that
product that i use at home i can then
turn it into a new product with preserve
um
next slide please john you want to add
on here sorry please just to take us
back for a second to the to the take
back story we had an interesting
discussion with reid beforehand of
sort of the history of some of the take
back programs out there i think you guys
are familiar with you know the
ubiquitous milk bottle returns that
happened you know um years ago i think
when eric launched the company in
1996 this idea of pulling a toothbrush
back was
if not the first plastic article
consumer products take back it was close
to it it was really sort of leading
ahead of its time
just to
maybe get into this later but a little
bit now um
when we you know we first started
thinking about recovering materials uh
the the foundation of preserve was was
really about helping the recycling
industry
to create the demand side so there was a
lot of recycling that was going on in
the early 90s but there wasn't there
wasn't the evidence of companies taking
those recycled materials and actually
turning them into two products so the
mission and part of preserve was to help
the demand component of the recycling
industry by proving that companies could
utilize these recycled materials that
more and more consumers were uh taking
you know their own hard work and
recycling and turning them into new
products so that was one of the core
foundations of the founding of of
recycling at the time and we're still
that's the background uh company name of
our of our company but we're mostly
known as preserve today
um transitioning into today i just
wanted to make sure we got this out um
we are b corp and have been for over a
year now
and we see this as a as a fantastic
movement in the united states to really
bring forward a structure that helps
companies
designate themselves as a a company
that's out there to do to do good to to
bring social value um and and most most
importantly to designate themselves as a
company that's not just about financial
value they have to go through the
process with their board of directors
with their stakeholders and say we're
going to change our bylaws and we're
going to say that we need to factor in
other value creation beyond financial
value in the decisions that we make in
running our company
so we love this music this movement um
we're we're a big part of it in the
sense that we're out there talking about
it a lot and i bring it up you know
quickly in this presentation the sense
that it this is really you know this is
where we are today
from
uh 15 years later from those early days
of you know really being a renegade
where people were kind of scratching
their heads going you know you're going
to do what you weren't going to take a
toothbrush back and and turn it into
what or you're going to take you know
recycled materials and make a toothbrush
out of it that that kind of
conversation back in the late 90s was
was sort of crazy talk
today it's not and there's a lot of big
companies that are taking steps to and
realizing that you know good business um
is is great for the earth and it's good
for their business as well
um start timeline over over time uh 1997
is when we launched the toothbrush
and we've dibbled and dabbled in a
couple funky products there that were
mostly uh customer driven um whole foods
market and wild oats both asked us to
come out with a tongue cleaner and
toothpick so we obliged um those still
are there today but in essence every
product that we choose we seek to make
it as light on the earth as possible and
it's primarily through sourcing number
five plastics and we'll talk more about
why we've chosen number five plastics
but
it's been a great decision um in the
early days choosing number five plastics
was mostly around the recycling
challenge that this material had
ones and twos had made some major
advances in the recycling participation
levels and number five was really left
behind so it's a great material to focus
on as it related to
trying to help the demand side of
recycled materials
um just a couple of
of core tenants of our business we make
everything in the united states of
america
um that that went along with our
environmental commitment we wanted to be
close to source we wanted to make things
here close to where we were cycling
yogurt cups and a lot of other things
and we were distributing primarily
united states so we wanted to make here
everything here in the united states
this has definitely become something
that more and more companies are are
interested in doing and obviously more
consumers are seeking products that are
made the united states of america it's
it's primarily based on the economy but
it's great that a number of companies
are also choosing it from an
environmental impact standpoint
no animal testing from day one bpa free
as you all probably know polypropylene
very rarely has bpa in it but we do do
tests on our materials to ensure
that we are bpa free gimme five we'll be
talking about that more that's
the evolution of our take back program
but we have some slides that speak
specifically to it
everything is is dishwashable washable
and we'll emphasize the the reusable
nature of most of our products as well
so here we introduce the the vehicle
we're going to talk a lot about today
we've moved from that old mailer that
used a lot of resources
to
our package
and our package now
the delivery vehicle of our toothbrush
to our consumer is also now
our mailback take back vehicle
so it also has gone through some
evolution that evolution has been
its first purpose was
we will take back your product and use
this mailer to put it in and we're going
to pay for the postage of that as well
that really designated the program as
sort of a front-runner and extended
producer responsibility
but also we've also taken it a next step
and that next step is to really get
across
uh some of the messages that we want to
get across like joining the gimme five
community becoming someone who is an
advocate for recycling and also learning
about how you can mail back in bulk to
reduce one our postage costs yes but
also to reduce your impact as well the
more that you you know get other people
in your dorm together to put a box of
toothbrushes to preserve or our bottle
ship which i think we'll talk a little
bit more about um
it gets more resources back to us in a
more efficient way
and i think while we're here it's worth
pointing out we've gone through a lot of
trouble throughout entire history to
make sure this toothbrush comes back to
us but we extend this to all of our
products so if we go back a couple
slides and think about that portfolio
whether it's the handle one the razor
the tongue cleaner or cutting boards and
colanders which should last you a very
long time we want to make sure we've got
some vehicle to get those back and
that's part of the evolution of why we
think we need a gimme five program
that's got more of a been in a store
which we'll get to of course
one of the um and one of the early
thoughts of the take back program for
preserve was also that the toothbrush
was made of multiple materials
and so you couldn't easily just throw it
in your curbside bin even if back in
1997 they would have taken you know a
number five part but it had bristles so
we knew that it had to have some kind of
a system that would bring it back to be
able to turn in to be able to be turned
into another uh product we had to take
control of that process because it had
it was a multi-material part
um introducing the gimme 5 program here
so back in 2005
we
had 10 years almost running of taking
back
both number five plastics to make our
products
encouraging people to recycle number
five plastics as well as working with
communities to help them
improve their processes of recycling
number five
and also taking back our products from
uh when they're
done with their useful lives but we
still had consumers saying i think it's
great what you're doing i think it's
great that you're using recycled
materials
but i still can't recycle my sour cream
container or my yogurt cup
what are you going to do about it
um so we said or we're going to take it
back so we are now going to start a
program that's both mail in
and has bins at retail where we'll take
back number five packaging and through
partners like whole foods market convert
that material into a feed stream to make
our products
so the gimme five program was started at
park slope food co-op in in brooklyn and
we had about a two-year pilot there
and it was very successful there are a
lot of people in brooklyn the new york
area that would uh you know find out
this location where they could bring
their number five plastics that weren't
recyclable in their community
and you know we're also finding that
even though
there are you know some uh number five
single stream collections
around that area or around areas where
give me five bins exist
that consumers love the fact that
they're able to really identify that
feed stream of a yogurt cup and that it
turns into a product here you know in
massachusetts or in in michigan it's
just a state that they can identify that
everything is staying here in the united
states of america and that you know that
they know that full supply chain
um
so we're going to talk a bunch more
about the gimme five program but this is
really the the genesis of it was
please solve my problem i think it's
great what you guys are doing but um if
you're trying to help out recycling
number five i still got a problem here
and you need to help me figure it out
just a couple of highlights uh we you
know we have gotten awards and
recognition to preserve which is great
for a number of our products
um so that's always wonderful to have
and particularly this package this
package was very novel a package that
provides for that pays the postage for
bringing your product back to the
company that made it that was
revolutionary
particularly in this category
just giving idea of some of the
retailers that we work with
we are a nationally distributed uh
company now and we have five categories
of products um it was it has been
difficult to bust into the mass market
um we're having more and more success
today um i think i hope it's something
that comes out today we want to talk
about you know is is a uh
an epr program um a take back program a
competitive advantage
um
we'll talk about it some more i think in
question time but it certainly has been
a real challenge for us um it has not
been a competitive advantage until uh
you know the more more recent years
where a retail buyer might say oh i get
that you know a retail buyer 10 years
ago or 15 years ago definitely did not
get that that was something that was um
disturbing really
so changing consumer behavior
um i
want to speak to
the evolution of preserve and you know
as we're starting this company three or
four years out we're doing something
different um and then we're realizing
that we've got a platform we've got a
platform to inform a platform
to help green consumers be more green
and you know this seems very uh almost
mainstream i think probably to most
people in the room today that you know
you can have access to information or
companies
you know that help you act more green
um but but you know back in the late 90s
it wasn't and so as we were turning this
the the century um you know we loved the
fact that preserve was really a gateway
product it was a product it was a
company that people could come to to
very uh quickly and easily make a
difference in their everyday life
um
it's a far cry from building a building
like like we're in today so it's it's a
very easy step at preserve to join a
green movement right on and i've seen um
as as we've gone out there more and more
and seen more and more opportunities
back on the retail slide to get our
products in front of people that this
point has been debated a bit is is that
easy step really going to lead to those
bigger steps is the the green product
purchase gonna keep you rolling and the
next thing you know you're in a hybrid
car or maybe you've gotten rid of your
car all together i find um
the literature to be uh
exciting right now people writing about
this and saying well we don't really
know and it's interesting on the ground
with us to talk to consumers and say oh
yes you know i had a life-changing
moment i started buying preserve and it
kept me going because it was like if i
can buy a toothbrush made from recycled
content maybe i can take those next
steps or maybe i've gotten invited into
a larger community if you go on flying
you bought your preserved toothbrush and
you start googling around you find
people who are living sort of
interesting alternative lifestyles
there's a blogger on the west coast
who's living pretty much a plastics free
lifestyle except for a few things and
the preserved toothbrush is one of them
and we're thrilled she talks about it a
lot talks about the take back program
and sort of introduces those people to
this other way of perhaps living
um it's a great place to be in uh when
we think about when i say great place
consumer products and and being green
and being on the forefront of
the consumer products industry and
trying to reduce our impact when you
think about the impact that we're all
having on the earth
it's it's more easily defined i think in
eating transportation home climate i
think people associate
and understand where they're having an
impact in those three
quadrants um the fourth consumer
products i think you know it's starting
to have its effect now but i think it
was more challenging for someone
years ago to understand the impact
they're having when they're choosing a
product the thinking about the supply
chain of that product reaching them and
what's having how it's happening to that
product after they're through with it
so that's a it's it's an exciting place
for us to be in and obviously the impact
is there 29 of us emissions uh happen in
the uh the sourcing production and
delivery of consumer products in the
united states
i think we all we've all probably seen
this type of slide before and and we all
know that um we're here for a reason um
if everybody consumed the way we do in
the united states we need fibers to
support that level of consumption
so there's a lot of a lot of work to do
every day
and we're happy to be involved
let's start in sure
in our efforts to change consumer
behavior
we
took a magnifying glass to one of our
lines of plate wear we introduced a
plate wear line a few years before the
one you you're seeing on the slide here
that was made from recycled
polypropylene that was reusable you
could put it in your dishwasher and wash
it it could go in the microwave we felt
pretty good about things we've taken a
single use throwaway category made some
big headway
a few years down the road we were
getting some inquiries on you know gosh
this is great do you guys want to do
another line of plate wear
okay sounds fantastic we'd love to where
do you want to go and my reaction in a
number of our reactions we want to go
that really really lightweight plate
let's let's cut all the impact out of it
and through some sessions with some
advisors one of the things that came up
to us and i'd seen this anecdotally as
well is well these plates you already
have out there today sure they can be
thinned up but what's going to happen to
them if you do and i've been to you know
social situations where some would throw
a party and the plates would end up in
the garbage can sometimes a little
better they ended up in the recycling
bin but these these were plates very
clearly in my mind meant to go in the
dishwasher and so when we went around
well let's find out where that line is
what makes a plate reusable and we found
pretty obvious things there's a
heaviness to it a stiffness to it and so
we sat down with a group of consumers
and a number of plates and i wish i had
that shot of the woman fiddling with one
of the plates on this slide and we found
that there's this line and we carved
weight or added weight however you want
to look at it
to make a plate about this weight
got a certain stiffness to it and then
added in some other features to make
sure that the reusability aspect just
sort of hits you over the head so um
on on the back of it the whiting that's
in right there is in you know molded
into the back of the plastic we just you
do that to make it come out um there's
the reuse forever sort of
staring you in the face there's a date
of manufacture so people can look at and
say wow i've had this plate for 20 years
we'll hit one of those dates i'm sure um
uh and and i think interestingly some of
the things to say that sustainability
really is for everyone we wanted to
reach out and put braille on the back of
this plate um
as as we we looked at it we said you
know there are a few more subtle things
we can do the the curved handle and the
curved around the rim adds a little
stiffness to it um and then finally
pretty importantly the texture the
texture conceals knife marks we found in
our conversations with people of okay
you are going to reuse this plate when
are you going to throw it away it's like
oh when it gets marred up and
too scratched up i said okay great let's
add some texture here and see if we can
try to hide those knife marks
and this has been a really fun category
in the sustainability space because it's
um it's been it's been revolutionary
from you know the statement that we're
trying to make they're reusable plastic
wear out there before this came but to
emphasize that we want you to reuse this
forever and we're doing this deep
research to make sure it's going to be
there for you for all those years
we're pushing the envelope on trying to
change behavior just trying to help
people to understand that you know you
can you can opt away from paper plates
or styrene throwaway plates and to think
about you know not only how this thing
is made but how you use it every day
so it's been a really fun place to be in
some of the you know some of the buyer
meetings that you have at retailers are
challenging you know when you're walking
out of the the buyers meeting and he's
all excited about um this new product
line he loves the look of it he loves
the colors of it he loves the fact it's
made out of recycled materials in the
united states of america and i remember
this meeting very well you're walking
down the hallway and then it's it was a
bj's um the guy says to me
am i going to sell less of them
because it's reusable
and i had a hard time not saying yeah
yes you are going to sell less of them
but you know you're going to be in the
beginning you're going to be that one
place that people can go for this so
hopefully it'll add to your category but
the bottom line is
you're going to sell less people are
going to reuse them and that's what we
should be working towards
here's um
a great emp uh you know so the next
generation of that next step on that is
called shareware
so we had heard and just saw developing
with a lot of our uh preservers that
there are communities which are uh
buying one set of our product our
reusable tableware and then announcing
to everybody in the community that
they've got them and please come over to
my house and pick them up and use them
for your next function so we we took
that and we loved it and we
established what we call preserve
shareware so it's the ultimate reuse you
were using in your home but then reuse
it in your community
this has been you know another
interesting place to be in and sort of
emphasizing that we have to reuse
earth's resources to make our products
but once we have our products we got to
reuse them as well
got it and i think there's been a um
an explosion recently in in this topic
i've seen it all over the press and a
number of sites that are trying to
facilitate the action and we've had an
interesting
eternal internal not eternal internal
debate around
are we the hub where folks register and
try to share their preserved plate ware
yet we've seen a number of sites and
memories failing me now a number of
sites where people are registering to
share their power tools to share their
kayaks and we think as those sort of
develop
pick some winners out of there and try
to get our preserved share wares into
those communities and hopefully we're
off to the races with this
so we're going to dive deeper into the
mailback uh program now in the uh
package itself right and specifically
toothbrush focused
um this is just laying out the stages of
our company in um you know it's just
sort of very general terms but in the
first 96 of 2007 uh we're really uh you
know proving out the model and uh
launching our products and primarily in
the natural channel from 2000 and 2000
2008 to 2011
we're bringing that concept that we've
talked a lot about so far of of
recycling encouraging the demand side of
recycled materials as well as take back
program
into in really integrating sustainable
design
bringing in outside
consultants as well as hires to really
emphasize
sustainable design and partners as well
we work very closely with a partner
called continuum so really bringing in
the sustainable design components into
the the development of our products
and also setting up some key
partnerships to make sure that we're
going to be successful as a you know a
for-profit company in the sales and
distribution and marketing of our
products
in 2012 and beyond we've talked about
our b corp establishment
as well as uh we're now at a point where
we're really investing in the gimme five
program and we're going to talk more
about that but it's also it's not only
the network of recycling that we're
creating but also the community of the
recyclers and seeking to bring these
people together to to continue to
galvanize this this effort to bring
number five recycling
much further along the path than it
should be today
or where it is today
so um i chose this slide as the
beginning to a small set of slides to
describe the
the product develop product design
packaging design effort that went into
taking us from our
old and and still sold toothbrush
canister into this new lightweight
mailbackpack
and to set the stage a little bit for
you as eric's talking about the
continuous improvement timeline there
a few years ago preserve was going
through a fairly major rebranding effort
with with our partners at continuum um
and you know we were reaching back and
sort of touching our roots about what
what did we believe in and these are
some some of the statements that that
came out of
some copywriting meetings and at that
same time we're realizing that we have a
toothbrush package that really needs an
update certainly on the branding side we
could easily see that but at the time
the toothbrush which was
made of recycled yogurt cups um had a
postage paid take back program to give
it another life um was sold in a rigid
plastic container that was a fantastic
travel or storage case but you didn't
need it every time i mean your dentist
tells you replace every three months
maybe people do it every six months but
you need this canister once every three
years um if that and so we realized boy
we've really got to do some updating on
this and you went back to our values and
we're like gosh why do we even packaging
at all and and some of the the bars that
were set to come up with this next
package was well it should be a real
revolution in a package it should show
people
and
aspire to show people the way that
packaging should be done in the
sustainable products industry
so
with that sort of as the background i'm
going to jump forward to sort of our
solution and then talk a bit about it
we came up with a package that in some
ways
could have been categorized we could
have gone down the road and making it
into a cheap polyethylene bag
could have been up there like candy and
could have cost pennies
we we chose a bag nevertheless because
of the the lightweight the flexible film
um it was extremely lightweight but we
put wrapped it in polypropylene ended up
having to abandon an all polypropylene
package because we just couldn't
manufacture it and most films and and
bags you see today have a little bit of
another material in them in this case
for us it was polyethylene and allowed
us to make this package that feels and
we've got samples for everyone that
feels high-end that feels like
that feels akin to that travel canister
that you bought and you were happy to
pay for
these are a few
call outs on the package i mentioned the
lightweight
the postage paid mailer to enable
recycling
and this thing over here says return to
preserve for recycling one of the things
i loved about this was it really
screamed at the consumer send me back
send me back we want to go back i want
to have another life
um
this this package reduced our our
footprint dramatically um
ran the the life cycle assessment on
this with um
the sustainable packaging coalition's
tool and we came out far ahead of where
we were before and we came out far ahead
of say you're um
not to talk about other toothbrushes but
to come out far ahead than your typical
toothbrush sold in your cardboard
blister pack um felt like we had a great
revolution even without the postage paid
mailer on here
um john hold on
um
it's pretty i mean
if you're a marketing person and you're
in consumer products and you're looking
at this
you're saying yourself
you're talking about everything but how
well this toothbrush works
and i can't see this toothbrush and this
is really challenging for me so in
meetings with buyers at the targets of
the world um they really pushed on us
with that it really pushed on us and
this was the first package that you know
had a hero shot of the toothbrush but
you couldn't see it
at least as far as we knew in the mass
channels there really was not a package
uh in which you couldn't see the product
and then you've got powered by recycled
yogurt cups as your first message you've
got easy to recycle in the middle and
then you've got made in the usa are the
most prominent things there um there is
a dentist design but that that was uh
emphatic and
in a positive
uh
that's a very positive side but in
addition our sales went up 40 percent at
target when this product launched so it
was very well received by even the
mainstream shoppers
we've made made this point a couple of
times but i think it's uh in fact to
make it again we pay for the postage to
get these toothbrushes back um
when we
introduced the package we started
getting a lot of toothbrushes back our
rates dropped dramatically and in with
this package today we get about 20 of
our toothbrushes back they give you a
comparison when you talk about um
pet soda bottles it has a fair bit of
infrastructure to collect them it's
about 30 percent recycling rates i know
they can be debated a little bit but i'm
in the ballpark i'm sure um and we
managed to with our package get 20 of
our toothbrushes coming back
the hard part is this this is this is an
expensive program to run and the
consumers who are doing this are unknown
to us there's 20 of our consumers are
going through the step to make sure the
toothbrushes come back to us and doing
the things that we we want them to do
nevertheless they've remained anonymous
to us so we've decided just recently to
continue to evolve the program
and go on the next slide
continue to evolve the program and still
pay for the postage still still in our
blood we want to pay for the postage to
get these toothbrushes back but we want
to evolve the program so that we can
feasibly pay to get all of them back and
i know we're a little bit like the the
news we're going to talk about gimme
five in a second
and talk a little bit about how we're
doing that to give me five but with our
toothbrush package we realized sort of
the key insight
eric mentioned the postal service
earlier it turns out that when you put
one toothbrush in this package or
somehow if you were to magically be able
to stuff six toothbrushes in the package
the unit cost is the same to us
so we decided boy if we could get people
online
give them the postage paid
insignia
and encourage them instead to ship it
back in say a water bottle where you can
put six toothbrushes
we've cut our cost dramatically
and this is the the bottle ship that we
refer to today
we drive people online they sign up each
toothbrush has a unique code printed on
the package so we're doing a couple of
things
we're trying to get to know you second
thing we're doing is we are ensuring
you've bought a preserved toothbrush
over the years of having the
postage-paid insignia we have gotten
some strange things back
rather not we'd like to know you're
really going to send us toothbrushes
back so now okay they bought a
toothbrush we're a lot closer um
and this is this is the evolution of
that
i would just only add that i think you
covered it john but that the bottle ship
was one of those we seek aha moments at
preserve we really want people to go ah
they did it again um and the bottle ship
is one of those moments where people
look and they say i can take my
used water bottle or soda bottle and
stuff six toothbrushes in it put the
label that you're you know you're
printing for me with postage on it and
put that in the mail and
the post guy is really going to take it
that's fantastic i love it i hope you
did the research on that
anyway it's working out fantastically
so we're going to transition here um
just to let you know sort of what's
coming up and doing a time check we're
gonna do
two sets on gimme five we're gonna talk
a little bit here about
gimme five its founding and where we are
today with it and then we're gonna do a
little brainstorming about gimme five
where we are today and look at number
five plastic recycling in general and
perhaps where we can go with the program
so number five plastic recycling rates
um they're they're low they're one
percent and this is looking at all of
the poly pro polypropylene resin in the
u.s household waste stream um
see the numbers for pet for hdpe a bit
more respectable and then you see this
graph over here on your left and it
shows the amount
of
that resin in the waste stream you see
polypropylene rising dramatically and
this is this speaks a little bit to the
versatility and the wonders of
polypropylene um
eric mentioned earlier we've chosen
polypropylene for a reason when you go
um
and look at a life cycle assessment of
polypropylene maybe cradle to gate so
look at the the beginning of it coming
out of the ground to a pound of resin in
your hand polypropylene is one of the
lightest plastics on the earth that's
out there
i know there's with bioplastics there's
some challenges to that these days but
compared to pet we're doing a lot better
as well when um
folks go and do a screen on
polypropylene as far as its toxicity and
health and safetyness it comes out ahead
of most others so this is rising
polypropylene in the waste stream in
some some sense makes makes a lot of
sense to us um but it's this this one
percent that's been a real a real
problem for us real struggle yeah i just
only emphasized that it since we started
preserve it has become the most produced
plastic in the united states of america
yet the recycling rates remain at you
know less than two percent so it's a
it's a remains a fantastic crusade to be
on to improve the recovery of this now
most chosen plastic material
starbucks made a big change from moving
from p-e-t to polypropylene um mostly
because of um
health concerns health concerns and
greenhouse gas they looked they did a
cradle gate oca on their
um
cold drink cups and they went from p-e-t
to polypropylene and and splashed
it seemed ev everywhere to me anyway
they splashed all over that there were
pretty significant greenhouse gas
reductions in its manufacture um
and have since become and continued to
be uh pretty big proponents of
polypropylene and polypropylene
recycling
when we talk about polypropylene
recycling recycling in general i think
there's a number of templates out there
to look at and say well how should we
approach this problem and this is one
that um being a company that
someone described to me once as you guys
are seemed steeped and cradle to cradle
and i've always liked to to remind
ourselves that actually the cradle to
cradle in that book not thinking but
that book came out later than we were
founded um maybe somehow we influenced
that but
nevertheless the the the organization
being steeped in cradle to cradle we
gravitated towards this pretty quickly
um
actually just give a little plug here
there was a a yale um intern working for
us over the summer who as we were laying
the groundwork for gimme five came to me
with this and like this is beautiful
wouldn't this work really well and this
is intelligent materials pooling
it's come from michael braungart of
mcdonough and brian garden the cradle of
cradle work
so eric's covered a little bit the
history of gimme five um
in a nutshell go back to 2000 2001 stony
field farm is coming to us saying we've
got polypropylene cups coming from our
our manufacturing site can you recycle
those into a toothbrush handle yes we
certainly can we tell that story for a
while people kept coming saying well
that's great but i still have more
yogurt cups what should you do about
them and we started the work at uh in
brooklyn at the co-op there
piloted in a few more whole foods and
then i believe in 2008
we launched two whole foods and said you
know what we're going to put a ben in
the front of the stores collect
polypropylene bring it back through our
system and recycle it into the handles
of our products
and i'll talk a bit more a little bit
about the the down and dirty of those
operations um but it's been interesting
to find a group of brands that wanted to
come together help sponsor the program
it's not a free program in fact it's
when we look at the material we source
it's by far our most expensive material
to source so when we think about other
places we can find recycled
polypropylene even with the low rates
we're able to find polypropylene for far
cheaper than we can pull it back to the
grocery stores and clean it up
nevertheless um group of brands stony
phil bretta bert's whole foods and green
mountain coffee roasters come on boards
and we'll help you do this in one way or
another we've got various programs that
we run with each one of these people not
going to go into
detail on each one um if folks would
like to see that and certainly hit our
website or chat with us afterwards we
can go into some of the detail on how we
serve each one of these folks
yeah but most importantly they're coming
to this program to help fund the
recovery of the number five uh plastic
in their package or their products
so just to walk through for a second a
little bit the operations of say the
gimme five program
there's the ben um you'll find this bin
in a whole foods market um it's often in
the cafes
it advertises recycle your number five
plastic here right now we've got one
rule for the gimme five program and that
it's clean stamped number five
that
lands in the bin there
you guys understand this of course whole
foods grocery store every day there's
trucks full of goods that show up and
unload and they're empty or partially
empty the number five gets on those
trucks and is eventually transported
back hold back to the distribution
centers
from there there's a little bit of a qc
check on what's inside there
polypropylene is then aggregated up it's
bailed it's densified put together in
truckload quantities and then
we come and pull it into our supply
chain where we're doing a hand sort on
it and sort it out into a couple of
different streams with various criteria
and then a fairly typical
polymer reprocessing operation we're
grinding we're washing drying and then
re-melting down to get the the plastic
pellet
i've got a little sample here
people can come look at a little bit
closer later it's a light gray
looks like we ground up yogurt cups and
molted them and that's essentially the
process
in doing all of this one of the things
that we wanted to do and we did this
pretty quickly out of the gate with the
gimme five program was to run a life
cycle assessment this is cradle to gate
this is a pound of recycled
polypropylene from the gimme five
program and a pound of virgin
polypropylene
i think the the
the benefits here um are fairly typical
of polymer reprocessing programs that we
see um
p e t h d p e they also show
similar results to these and it's you
know great for us to know that even with
the gimme 5 program and maybe some of
the added transport that we're doing
we're nevertheless able to show
significant environmental benefit
these are our collection results over
the past couple of years um
you can see that we we've been in 10
regions of whole foods about 250 stores
last year we collected about 242 000
pounds and
turns out to be a very nice equivalent
metrics for yogurt cup 16 million yogurt
cups um
no doubt there's a lot more plastics in
grocery stores to collect um
but this has been a really great start
for us a couple of things to mention
before we move on the gimme five bin
collects not only clean stamp number
five but it collects the specific
products from some of our partners so
bretta approached us as we were
launching the game e5 with a specific
problem while they didn't have a classic
number five cup to be recycled they had
a water filter that um was made out of
number five inside contained your
charcoal and your ion bio and resin
beads to do the um the water filtering
they approached us and said we'd love to
have a take back program around this and
we think the first steps are
setting up an infrastructure where
consumers can bring this maybe even mail
it in and let's try to split it out and
recover the various bits of what's in
this
so we've been able to do that for them
as well we are now targeting people with
other sort of similar hard to recycle
packages so burt's bees the iconic
little yellow lip balm tubes um you guys
are all fairly familiar with those
extremely hard to recycle in the sense
those aren't going to go into your
curbside never really be recycled they
can come back to us we can clean them up
and repurpose them you know back into
toothbrushes
the reason they're they're gonna have
they're difficult to recycle is because
the size of them the lip balm tubes they
kind of get lost in the process
um and brita also
um was getting pressure in the united
states to have a program that brought
back their filter they had it in in the
european
continent but they didn't have the
united states and they found gimme five
um just quickly we've talked about some
of this already but this is sort of lays
out the relationship that we have with
stonyfield farm
we love uh as we mentioned partnerships
and stonyfield really helps to bring out
the identity of our company as well as
to extend our mission to um you know
many more people than we'd be able to do
on our own so let we met them at an
earth event
you know can you convert a yogurt cup
into a toothbrush
we're not sure
we tried for about a year and a half we
have a partnership with umass lowell
and the plastics engineering department
helped us you know really move that melt
flow in the beginning it was a little
challenging for us we had a designated
melflow we had every time and a
much more identifiable stream of
material
and the yogurt cup was uh
had a much higher melt than we were used
to using
but we were able to to overcome those
and and today it's um it's a lot easier
to to move melt flows in a compounding
environment something that was
definitely not thought of back in you
know as far as i knew in industry back
in the 80s and 90s there wasn't really a
reason to do it you just push the button
on the virgin plastic
po purchase order um
we celebrated it in 2006 with a
co-branded toothbrush we've done some
other products for them
as well as we have
done some co-branded
products in our general merchandise so
we introduced with stonyfield farm a
specific mini
food storage container to help change
behavior a little bit as well
make a message on the container and also
encourage people to buy the 32 ounce
yogurts and then also use a food storage
container
to transport it when you're when you're
consuming
um one of the things we love about the
gimme five program is the community that
we're creating
and working with our partners to reach
more and more consumers
this just gives you an idea that with
all of our partners combined we have 4
million likes
so we're really in the facebook world
so we're really seeking to work and
invest with our partners and investing
in
the digital side of this to to help our
outreach um to those
consumers that are interested in uh the
recycle cycling advocacy that gimme five
offers
yes i just think in a nutshell when
we're talking about uh competitiveness
the ability to for a small company to
reach out to the number of consumers and
these other companies have been really
fantastic
just a couple of quick notes on the the
marketing side of gimme five so we do
have an app that enables people to um
find a give me five location near them
uh to understand who's the the recycling
leader in that location um and also to
receive news from each one of our
partners
and this really tries to embody
where gibby5 will be and hopefully a
year from now
but the number of different ways that
you can access information from our
partners
deals on products from our partners
but also to
communicate with each other and almost
sort of a little microcosm of recycling
consumers within facebook
and and share um you know some of the
efforts that you're doing to make a
difference through recycling with your
friends via social network
yeah so now we're going to run through
gimme five quickly again um
you guys recognize this of course so
we've been running this program for a
number of years where does polypropylene
recycling stand today um
there we go excuse me um
the good thing about polypropylene
recycling is with the advanta single
stream there's a lot more availability
it's almost up to this sort of 60
threshold where cp consumer package
goods companies are allowed to to
advertise as this
cup or this
article is recyclable no asterisk
required
nevertheless you guys all know from the
earlier slide those rates are still down
in the single percent
but the markets for recovered
polypropylene are extremely favorable
prices have been increasing lately in
the last couple of years a program like
gimme five if we chose would not have
any uh any
problem offloading our gaming five for
much higher than we could a few years
ago
our our material stream continues to
grow when we go do an audit we find up
to 60 brands of yogurt cups in the
stream and that's not in all reasons i
think if we were to go do more regions
we could probably push that number over
a hundred
and interestingly recyclers are now
targeting grocery store for sources of
polypropylene and rigid hdpe and this is
the polypropylene and
polyethylene that's coming out of their
back end their buckets their tubs
probably fairly fairly straightforward
but in general the recycling
of a material the cost of bringing that
material to a manufacturer like us
is generally a static cost structure
compared to sourcing virgin plastic
materials so virgin is going to have
much more fluctuations with the price of
of oil or natural gas whereas in general
r should be fairly static because it's
really all about the processing costs of
bringing that material through
the biggest cost fluctuation is either
based on it being a substitute for a
virgin or also the transportation
expense which does fluctuate with oil
um
the bad there's still a lot of work to
be done here polypropylene a lot of food
in it there's a lot of cleaning up to do
as well polypro not all polypropylene is
the same thing whereas your your pet
soda bottles are fairly familiar and as
you recycle them you can handle a little
bit of some of the other poly
polyethylene that's out there when you
look at polypropylene the melt flows
vary combining them sort of turns them
into mud you don't get anything better
you're not able to take them back to a
normal state and there's still a good
bit of reprocessing technology and work
that needs to go into making sure that
we're not degrading the value of the
polypropylene as it's being recycled
and on the design for recycling side
there's still a lot of work to be done
around colorability a a light gray
uh plastic is extremely hard to turn
into a white yogurt cup if not
impossible um
and additives that are coming into the
system or they allow packagers a lot of
innovation they're challenging our
recycling for sure
and the ugly
polypropylene recycling is going to face
the same challenges that these these
resins face these resins have had
effort applied for a number of years to
them they're not very high
and i don't think you know certainly the
group in this room and the group will
buy our products are going to be happy
with this 21 or 11 rates
um so i'm gonna in the interest of time
move through
to a couple of different slides um this
slide really quickly started out as a
joke i wanted to see how complicated i
could make the value chain for
polypropylene i stopped when i realized
this was this was plenty complicated
enough but the idea here is this is the
supply chain for recycled polypropylene
and as we go and look at moving
polypropylene recycling rates who do we
want to bring in the room and i've seen
this approach from other other companies
starbuck famously runs what they call
cup summits where they're trying to
understand how do they get their paper
cup recycle there's some basic
recyclability challenges there one of
the things they did was they look down
at the supply chains but let's bring all
the people into the room let's bring the
paper recyclers let's bring the paper
cup makers let's bring the retailers
they brought everybody into the room and
start discussing solutions and we think
we've got a solution that could perhaps
be applicable like that
and here's give me five with a little
bit of a different take there's your
branded partner
your whole foods retailer
berry plastics may need a little
introduction they're one of the larger
polypropylene packaging manufacturers in
the united states and then brassica
is the poly the virgin polypropylene
resin maker for most of the
polypropylene in the united states of
america and here's that supply chain
approach for pulling all these folks in
and yet there's another approach
that speaks a lot which is let's just
focus on the branded partners let's pull
in more than one yogurt cup company
let's pull in a yoplait and a dan and a
chobani pull all of those folks together
and this this
you know perspective these are these are
happening um some of the names will
change we're sort of just throwing up
the the largest manufacturers here
um but it was what's intriguing about
gimme five uh and being the cooperative
that it is in bringing together
companies to to solve a problem
um it's intriguing in a lot of ways it's
intriguing to consumers when they see
companies working together to sort of
solve uh one one one company's waste
problem and create a product from it
with another company
but then it's also intriguing to see
companies that are competitors
in this marketplace possibly really
working together closely to solve an
environmental challenge and create a
solution
so we've had uh situations like this in
in the gimme five history where
competitors have have agreed to work
together um our partners have changed
over time um but this is a bit of a
vision that we have that could come into
fruition in a couple of years okay and
so with that we'd like to open it up to
questions
feel free to drag us wherever you'd like
um yeah it's really great i've watched
your products over the years so i'm
delighted to meet you guys and hear the
story i just was curious uh about the um
thank you i was curious
where you get how you source your
materials for your food grade products
given that the gimme five and the
post-consumer curbside materials as what
you said are not currently usable to
produce those so sort of what's a part
of your food grade sourcing for pee pee
and what's your non-food grade and where
is the non-food grade going to
certainly um
so food grade we've got a number of food
grade products um there are a couple of
post-consumer polypropylene resins on
the market today there's a company that
we're in a public partnership with
called next life who is sourcing a
strictly controlled collection of used
polypropylene they provide pcr food
grade as well when we started we started
reaching out into the pre-consumer or
post-industrial recycled polypropylene
market
that market is fairly well established
manufacturers have rejects have things
they can't reuse in their processes and
those end up in our food grade products
worth noting that gimme five is about 20
of the material that we use today
um and there's john had mentioned we
have a number of partnerships with
material reprocessors throughout the
united states and we we work with them
to source both pre-consumer
post-industrial as well as post-consumer
materials
post-consumer feed streams primarily go
into our toothbrush or our razor
and then anything that's food related
has a pre-consumer business to business
or or at times a post-consumer business
to business relationship if it's a
controlled source
in addition we're doing research with
one of our partners
to ultimately have a curbside food grade
post-consumer feed stream
there you go so um
thank you for that question uh so the so
this other 80 you mentioned that some of
these sources were cheaper
economically and i'm wondering how they
compare environmentally to the product
consumer product take back
great question um
one of the other lca results we didn't
show on here was looking at a
pre-consumer or post-industrial stream
which which we sourced we're not very
public with that information we tried
frankly to control the stream a bit um
and we looked at that and the results
are extremely similar to the gimme five
program um in fact with that there's a
little bit less washing there's a little
bit less transport it actually comes
across
to be
at least on the lca results more of a
benefit
but i think you can have some some
arguments around that because that's a
pretty
likely to be used recycled stream as
opposed to the stream that comes through
gimme five we feel like if we don't have
this stream out there it's not going to
be recycled
i didn't just add that that you know 15
years ago um
it was a novel concept to take your the
the materials that are coming out of the
back end of your operations that were
plastic and and seek to reuse those
um
and today we'd like it to be you know
more of a of a crime that you're you're
actually not reprocessing some you're
not getting the dollars that you could
in the secondary market in selling those
plastics to someone who can reuse them
and as john was mentioning some of that
material that business to business
recycling whether it's pre or post
um can can have the lightest impact and
i think we all know that there's still i
think probably perhaps majority of that
material is is not being converted into
a good secondary use
here in the united states
can you also say really quickly what's
the stumbling block or why isn't this
number five recycled through
conventional recycling chains or why
can't you go to a small region and say
look we want this we want to source it
so can you add it to your list of things
you take and
yeah take it from there i'll start with
the layman's and you can go into the
more technical but we won't take 90
minutes you know when we um
when we started preserve uh back then it
was really it was really that number
fives were left behind because the
recycling industry had focused on number
ones and number twos number one is the
number two so they're cash cow it was
the soda bottles and the milk jugs and
that's what was being recycled and
that's what they focused on
um so number two is we're we're really
left behind sorry number fives were left
behind in their process and ultimately
they were converted into
a contamination percentage into the
number two stream or hdpe
um so that that has been the biggest
reason why number fives have not gotten
the focus in the recycling
industry
really because it's a it's a it's a slow
moving industry
um you know today there are close to 50
percent of of communities that do offer
some kind of number five recycling you
know whether it's in single stream
whether it's co-mingled or not um and
and
we work with a number of recyclers and a
couple of whom are called leading
curbside recyclers they take things
other than number five
from from the curbside waste stream and
and recycle them into really great uh
pellets which end up into really great
products and packaging
the challenge that they've laid out a
number of times to us has been
with number two or number one we know
what we're looking for we're looking for
a soda bottle a detergent bottle or a
milk bottle with number five there's a
big huge list yogurt cups make a lot of
sense how many yogurt cups are in there
well compared to laundry detergent or
pet bottles
perhaps not enough to really get them
going and so as we look between that and
all of the other items out there
the end product they end up with a
reference mud earlier
and they end up with sort of a muddy
product that can't be recycled back into
a yogurt cup for sure um can it go into
park decking or
plastic lumber certainly
and the more that you're able to
to laser sort based on
on density um the more that they're able
to really you know get a stream over
here that they know is less contaminated
number five but again as john's saying
then then it's also okay can i can i
take every yogurt cup and put it over
here with this shape that i know is more
of an injection grade and then i've got
all these over here that are that are
thermoformed and i've got a big you know
differential and melt flows that make it
more challenging to put those two
together and make a good product but if
you could take them and really separate
them based on on shape and grade of
material within number fives then you've
got something that's very similar like
color sorting in the number two stream
so you know these days we can go to some
partners facilities where they're taking
number two they're chopping it all up
very similar melt flows and they're
taking the colors and they're
spraying them all over the place and
coming out with orange blues purples and
greens and it's incredible that are the
products that they're able to make on
the other side
yes
so you've given us an impressive and
ambitious impressive program ambitious
agenda um
i won't be the first person who asked
you about your economics i'm not asking
you to open the books i'm just asking
you to give us a sense
of whether you can really operate on
this scale
or what is it that enables you to
operate on a small scale
with
somewhat some high cost such as the
mailback program as you've already said
and so forth
great great question
um
we
we can operate on an expanding scale and
and be a profitable company we've been a
profitable company for a few years
we've elected to go out of profitability
here and there to invest in you know
additional expenses or capital tools
um
the i think one of the biggest uh
challenges that we've had as a company
is really when that
reply mail postage increased to a level
that we said this is really you know
starting to hurt a little bit um in
general the the additional sales that we
got out of the toothbrush base at the
targets of the world um you know that
that sort of gross margin dollars did
contribute well to the additional
postage that we had to spend
but that said this has been a great
change for us to bring this program
into
more of a structure in which the
consumer can elect to
based on more information bulk mail to
mail to us less frequently to do it more
efficiently with our help
and to be rewarded for it so we can
reward them with
products whether it's a mini for free or
a number of coupons what have you or
discounts from our store
we can reward them in a way that makes
it beneficial to both of us in the sense
that they're getting value and we're
getting value and we're covering um some
of that postage cost through through
other means of creating value with our
consumer
and just to speak for a second about the
the gimme five program and its economics
um if this wasn't
clear
the the program sponsor stony phil
bretta um
burt's bees that they pay into the
program to help us run the program and
cover some of those costs as well when
when we look at at what we're doing now
and i i reference 242 thousand pounds
there's a lot more plastic out there as
it go and say well we could scale this
up
that starts to make sense as we start
moving more plastic
it's it's a business that you need to
move a lot of volume and and we see the
local recyclers now starting to say i
want the
grocery store stream
we'd have some some changes to get
through and it is ambitious um some
changes to get through to get there but
as we see
recyclers coming to us with
hey i've got per curbside polypropylene
i see how to get food grade
polypropylene
we're buoying we're saying that's that's
exciting i could take this gimme five
program still run my take back program
cover the cost i need to and then put
this into that stream and i've got a
material that's much more viable
no
it sells
a lot more cups than the 16 million
yep and i think it's worth saying that
um
even today the take back program is is
not a competitive advantage for us
and it certainly wasn't in 1997.
um you know people were looking at us
like we had three eyes at that point
trying to do this um and and i and i
hope that it will be in five years that
would be fantastic that more and more
consumers preservers are realizing that
they want to support companies that are
taking responsibility you know for their
operations and trying to lighten their
operations as much as possible
where do we find our profit center
so that you can support to you know try
to
wait for the market to come to come in
on these other areas i'm really in the
in the sale of our products so in the
gross margin dollars that we bring into
our business based on the sale of our
products at retail at both brick and
mortar.com
our own website
we like to call them manufacturing
partners so they're they're you know
that we not contractors um or outsourced
we're very close to them um for instance
one of our manufacturing partners is in
sturbridge massachusetts and they make
um
majority of our our general merchandise
products um so we're we're very close to
them they actually have a percentage
ownership in our company um so we're
very tight with our manufacturing
partners but we don't have a
toothbrush manufacturing machine in
waltham so we do we generally um work
with those companies that they're the
best at making the products that we make
um and then we you know design the
package we designed the the tool uh
bring the tool to them and then ask them
you know to do it this way every day and
that's how they they they punch out our
products and we bring the material to
them as well
i have the impression as a layperson
that uh grocery products are constantly
changing
that the producers are always looking
for the the next gimmick to to catch the
consumer's eyes
um it doesn't sound like your products
um at the level of the individual
product line are constantly changing
style
how do you deal with you know that
fast-moving world when you're
you know you're the tortoise and they're
the hair
that's a fantastic question um
it's hard it's hard and it's conflicting
um
and i think one of the biggest biggest
conflicts i have you know in my job as
founder and ceo of a company that's
seeking to have a lighter impact is
dealing with that pressure from
um the
the the retail environment that we need
to sell somebody's you know widgets per
door per week
or we're out and that that's that's
probably one of the biggest uh pain
points of of
um you know our profession as a young
green consumer products company um
we don't we don't change uh styles much
and we hear that particularly in the
housewares show
it's you know where where's the new look
of the mixing bowl
what we've sought to do with every one
of our designs is bring forward natural
elements um you know beautiful
shapes and designs so that they are
long-lasting so those designs are not a
fad they're not trying to appeal to you
know the latest gripper they're really
using uh core functionality to make sure
it's gonna last for a long time the
preserved toothbrush has been with some
refinements been around since 97 and we
are looking at it saying do we want a
2.0 and even if we had a 2.0 we'd
probably we'd keep the iconic preserved
toothbrush um but i think that's the
answer and the only thing i'd add as
well
preserve has had a real color story to
it so we've really sought to bring out
um fresh different
natural looking colors um you know to to
help out the the
presence of our product in the shelf
more more um
you know just not mainstream colors and
in general the preserved toothbrush
thought came out with some uh pastels
that were never really seen in a
toothbrush before that had a little bit
of you know sort of stony filled gray in
them right
from the yogurt cup sources but we've
always looked at color as a way of
differentiating ourselves and i i have
a
quick reply to that as well um
as we we've grown and people have
started to identify oh you're playing in
this consumer product space you're going
to have to innovate and change one of
the engagements we've had that have been
that has been fantastic is from the
local sustainability community around
boston that's also heavy on the product
design and a few years ago as we were
relying upon
recycled content recyclability and take
back programs to carry our pro carry our
messages to be the sustainability roots
of preserve
i and and eric and others started to get
hip and learn more about this idea of
sustainable design of can we be a
company in 15 years where yes we're
going to be evolving and changing our
products and our looks but can we do
that in a sustainable way can we make
sure that every design that comes out
has a impact-reducing thrust and
remains to be seen i mean i think it's
institutional learning at a small
company
let's do two more and then give the guys
a break
hi thank you so much for your
presentation it was really fascinating
um i was just curious about
um your recycled plastics when you're
recycling them and recycling them how
often how long can it last before it
actually degrades and
are there are there new technologies in
place that may extend this lifetime sure
um
polypropylene is is a fantastic
polymer in that regard um it can be
recycled numerous times before it starts
to degrade and in fact in in some of the
work and research we've done
we've identified that it actually isn't
the recycling process that really
degrades the plastic it's exposure to uv
it's exposure to heat it's exposure to
other additives actually degrades it
more so the yogurt cup that i have
collected change in for 10 years it's
brittle it breaks i've seen it falling
apart
and that's just anecdotal anecdotal
evidence of
the fact that if i were to recycle that
yogurt cup i had to recycle it a number
of times before it gets to that stage
it's also worth you know worth noting
that with the um in the mathematics if
only
we get a lot of different streams but if
two percent are being recycled um it's
always being our our supply chain our
feed material is always being
rejuvenated if you will by a vast
majority of virgin materials into it
but your supply chain is contaminated
right especially in the e5 i know you're
hand sorting
to take back some of those things that
are not purely pp
but there is a degree of contamination
there's a degree of contamination but
we're pulling just the polypropylene
we're doing a positive sort on our gimme
five program and there is contamination
the inks on a yogurt cup is a really
fantastic example of that
the mineral fillers in a yogurt cup so
there are lightweight light
light cost
um
mineral fillers in a yogurt cup like
calcium and and those degraded yogurt
cup over time so as we're doing that
we're also i think i was trying to say
we're pulling in the next generation of
recycled material so it's you know um
generation one yeah it's rarely that
it's gone through two lives or yep
anything close to it by the time it's
gotten to
volume us your products in your supply
chain goes out the downstream side
could you repeat the question
on the downstream side just on a
follow-up question how much of your
product
goes out and who are your customers on
that end
do you recycle what you what you cannot
recycle you mentioned park benches
you've mentioned speed bumps
how much what volume of your product you
mentioned adding
virgin material there's obviously no i
think eric was referring to the the
first generation of recycled material so
what comes into our supply chain this is
its first time being recycled for
and what percent of this is being
recycled for the second time i don't
know
and i'm not sure if understanding let's
connect afterwards the question you've
mentioned that you're adding virgin
material all the time and there's also
some proportion of the material you
cannot recycle within to create your
products so on the downstream site do
you have customers for that material
right now so just make it i just want to
make clarification when i said um
we're making all of our products out of
recycled materials um so when it's
adding virgin it means that cup that's
been used before right it doesn't have
any recycled content in it we're
recycling we're turning into a
toothbrush
um the downstream side i think he's
referring to what does our toothbrush
turn into and our take back program turn
into right and we do have customers on
the downstream side of us we get back
um
black
black trays that i can't turn into
anything except for black toothbrushes
um it's not so great i could do that to
the cows come home so
where do we end up with this um and
there is a
because of who we are and what we've
been doing for these number of years a
number of contacts we can go to and say
we've got a source of recycled black
polypropylene
with one condition here we want it to be
made into a product in the usa and
that's that's what we've gone out to our
give me five partners and we get things
we can't recycle there's our one
condition when we move it on through we
don't do anything public with those guys
and sort of promote that we've kicked
that around a few times and not really
seen the value in it
is there no
do you make money on that is that a cost
for you guys
it's a cost yeah it's a cost
when we take back um our use preserve
products and convert them into another
product
that's that's a cost for us
um so if we're making toothbrushes from
toothbrushes for instance that's that's
a much more expensive toothbrush than
converting it from a yogurt cup into a
toothbrush
question in the back
hi
um so you touched a little bit on the
marketing side you said about the
packaging and how it's designed that
that you mentioned that obviously um
the strongest focus is on the
recyclability and not so much on the
functionality of the toothbrush and i
was wondering if it's different when if
the consumers have a different reaction
to that when it's uh different products
that are usually used more often i mean
we all throw a toothbrush to the garbage
like you said every three months well we
use uh you know uh plates longer than
that so do you see so a what's your
pricing range in that and b if you see a
difference between different categories
of products yeah um
yes absolutely and and we
uh i think i was making a bit of a point
there with a toothbrush and it's there
it's obvious we are emphasizing you know
that environmental side um when in our
general merchandise products mixing
bowls colanders
we we do a bit more emphasize the
functionality of it the performance of
the product
but you know there's a there's a bit of
a quandary there in the sense that
people are coming to preserve primarily
because we're a lower impact company
we're a green consumer products company
and we want to make sure they see that
but in addition we want to be able to
reach out to those consumers that are
the vast majority that just need a
colander
and be and introduce them to green
so while we know that it's the primary
driver for a majority of our consumers
we also want to reach those consumers
that are less interested so most often
with our product uh communication we do
lead with the performance side of our
products so if you look across our line
that's the usually um the the number one
message that's coming out
but strong second is the green component
in terms of pricing we always want to be
uh parity priced based on performance so
we we definitely uh from day one we want
a consumer to make no sacrifice in
choosing preserved products
whether that's with performance or with
pricing so our pricing seeks to be right
in line with a comparable product on a
performance basis regardless of its
green
components thank you very much
thank you very much
everybody
beautiful day it's hard to be inside
thank you